These long-burst brain waves are called delta waves.
When we don't get the deep sleep we need,
it inhibits our ability to learn
and for our cells and bodies to recover.
Deep sleep is how we convert all those interactions
that we make during the day
into our long-term memory and personalities.
As we get older,
we're more likely to lose these regenerative delta waves.
So in way, deep sleep and delta waves
are actually a marker for biological youth.
So naturally, I wanted to get more deep sleep for myself
and I literally tried almost every gadget, gizmo, device and hack out there --
consumer-grade, clinical-grade,
what have you.
I learned a lot, and I found I really do need, like most people,
eight hours of sleep.
I even shifted my circadian component
by changing my meals, exercise and light exposure,
but I still couldn't find a way to get a deeper night of sleep ...
that is until I met Dr. Dmitry Gerashchenko
from Harvard Medical School.
Dmitry told me about a new finding in the literature,
where a lab out of Germany showed that if you could play certain sounds
at the right time in people's sleep,
you could actually make sleep deeper and more efficient.
And what's more, is that this lab showed
that you actually could improve next-day memory performance
with this sound.
Dmitry and I teamed up,
and we began working on a way to build this technology.
With our research lab collaborators at Penn State,
we designed experiments in order to validate our system.
And we've since received grant funding from the National Science Foundation
and the National Institute of Health
to develop this deep-sleep stimulating technology.
Here's how it works.
People came into the lab
and we hooked them up to a number of devices,
two of which I have on right here --
not a fashion statement.
(Laughter)
When we detected that people were in deep sleep,
we played the deep-sleep stimulating sounds
that were shown to make them have deeper sleep.
I'm going to demo this sound for you right now.
(Repeating sound waves)
Pretty weird, right?
(Laughter)
So that sound is actually at the same burst frequency as your brain waves
when your brain is in deep sleep.
That sound pattern actually primes your mind
to have more of these regenerative delta waves.
When we asked participants the next day about the sounds,
they were completely unaware that we played the sounds,
yet their brains responded with more of these delta waves.
Here's an image of someone's brain waves from the study that we conducted.
See the bottom panel?
This shows the sound being played at that burst frequency.
Now look at the brain waves in the upper part of the graph.
You can see from the graph
that the sound is actually producing more of these regenerative delta waves.
We learned that we could accurately track sleep
without hooking people up to electrodes
and make people sleep deeper.
We're continuing to develop
the right sound environment and sleep habitat
to improve people's sleep health.
Our sleep isn't as regenerative as it could be,
but maybe one day soon,
we could wear a small device
and get more out of our sleep.
Thank you.
(Applause)